[Music]
all right tiffany
tiffany where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i'm from baltimore
maryland
baltimore and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents
growing up um
no my mom died when i was a baby and
my dad he lives in new york and i only
met him once i think i was eight years
old
when i met him and ever since then i
never heard from him
how did you lose your mom she died from
heroin overdose
oh wow so you ended up being raised by
who
my grandmother the hell was charlie
well
it was okay i guess growing up but
i used to get in a lot of fights since
elementary school
and um as i was growing up
at the age of 13 i think i'm not
mistaken if i don't if my memory serves
me correctly
i got on the party line and i met this
guy that was 29 years old on the party
line and um
i got caught in my grandma's basement
with him but i didn't do anything with
him at the time because i ended up
falling
asleep and he did too and i got caught
by my aunt's husband
and they ended up calling the police and
i ended up going to the hospital because
they wanted to make sure
nothing was wrong with me or whatever
but i never did anything with the guy
you know
i got in trouble for that so they had um
called my
grandmother out here to come get me
and she came from out here so you're
living where in baltimore maryland
in baltimore can we put the mask away
just put in your pocket or anyway there
you go
and what kind of kid were you in high
school oh
i was so far a good kid
until like my 10th grade year
i got in trouble again for getting on
the party line meeting another guy
and um i just got to put on punishment
got my cell phone taken i believe like
it was nothing like serious like that
but um
pretty much yeah it's hot in here no lie
sorry no wait no ac so
you started working the street at what
what age 16.
this was in baltimore uh no out here
oh you moved out here yeah okay and that
was with a pimp or by yourself
i was by myself
how did that go do you remember your
first time um yeah i do i was with this
mexican guy um it was actually one of my
friends
her dad um i dated him or whatever like
um
he took me to his house for his wife's
house and like he um gave me some money
some weed or whatever and like we had
sex and then he dropped me off at my
grandma's house
until this day he still i still call him
he still sees me but like
we don't do anything you know because
he's older he's like way older now so
like
he's kind of sick you know so did that
open up the
open up your mind to doing this yeah
fast money fast money easy
yeah did me is there any other
job you could get that would compete
money-wise for this
uh
well i don't know because i've had
plenty jobs and like i feel that
me standing at work for all these hours
for a little bit of nothing is like
a waste of time when i could stand on
the corner for five
minutes as soon as i step on the
concrete i'm catching a date for like
300 700 like it just all depends
yeah you get addicted to that
yes i'm addicted to it
are you using drugs as well
sometimes
you've had uh that experiences doing
this
um honestly
no you guys haven't been rough with you
when they pick you up or
rob you or not oh yeah yeah yeah that
happens all the time
actually i just recently got robbed
just for eleven hundred dollars
it's sad but i did like three weeks ago
you've been arrested before plenty of
times
i just got out of prison probably about
like 11 months ago
the federal prison what was that for uh
that was just for
a violation prostitution in california
doesn't really get you prison time
no i went to the feds
for some other [ __ ] that i used to do
but
i'm off probation on abortion now so i
have to worry about that
did you have kids um yes i have one son
are you raising him no who's he with
right now he's somewhere because um
he has an aggressive behavior problem so
they're trying to figure out what is
really
going on with him and why he's acting
out the way he is
of course because he misses me and he
needs me but
other other reasons why
would it be possible you turn towards me
a little bit awesome
does this lifestyle get you depressed
sometimes you get down
yeah sometimes i need some water
look at your water hold on please so
what i just asked you if you get
depressed sometimes
i'm depressed all the time tell you the
truth
honestly speaking i'm depressed all the
time
what do you think gets you down just
just this lifestyle is
not pretty much the lifestyle well
sometimes yeah but just the fact that
i'm a single mother i'm out here on the
streets doing this i don't have a stable
place to stay i'm dependent on a [ __ ]
who i'm really not that sure gives a
[ __ ] about me
so i don't know
are you saving money at all um well uh
yeah i am i'm not saving it i don't have
it in my possession but
i believe there's money being saved i
guess
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing about girls that do this for a
living
is from outside for people that don't
know what i think about what
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing people drive down figaro and
they'll see girls working the street and
just think oh these
yeah you know what there's been plenty
of times where i said like damn a [ __ ]
excuse my friend she can't even walk
down figaro without a person
stereotyping them thinking that they're
a prostitute like
how come i can't just be a regular girl
and walk to the store
or whatever the case may be like why do
i have to be a hoe
but 99.9 percent of the time
yeah any girl in a short skirt on figaro
is yeah
thought we're gonna pick he's doing
business
what was the best time of your life
the best time in my life that i had
when i had my son so far after that like
it's just
i i see myself like going downhill
because it's like a repeating pattern
that i keep doing and
either i'm gonna get it together or i'm
just gonna forever be
doing the street [ __ ]
yeah how old are you now i'm old
i'm 29. you're young i'm old i shouldn't
be doing this
at this age well no one should be doing
this at any age yeah yeah
yeah at any age but it's like i'm done
with it already i should be but hey
the money's good i gotta win
how do you think doing this for
for 14 years of your life has changed
you
well mentally it hasn't changed me
physically
i just lost some weight to try to look
good but
i don't think it's changed me it just
made me
more of a boss [ __ ] and a go-getter
you think your liberty will walk away
from this will i ever
yeah will you be able to oh yeah
most definitely
it sounds like you can stand back and
look at what you're doing and see the
craziness in it right
yeah the [ __ ] i had to go through
putting up with these tricks
[ __ ] wasting time like yeah
was it all worth it it's the question
do you think doing this has also changed
your the way you view men
yes most definitely especially the
married men
the married man i bet you a lot of your
customers are married right yeah
mary of course yeah
or they either just got out of a
relationship or they're not happy at
home
so they want to go out in the streets
and find a girl yeah
a lot of guys are addicted to it yeah to
it as well
sometimes it'll just be their fetish i
guess
yeah you've been in love before
yeah does this does doing this get in
the way of
those relationships no because i'm not
in a like a relationship relationship
like that
i mean like my [ __ ] that i'm with like
i don't know it's kind of weird but i
love him
but i'm not in love with him i love him
like i got love for him
he's been there for me he's helped me
he's put up with me
like i'm his headache
and i'm not going anywhere
do you think if your mom if you hadn't
lost your mom at an early age
your life would be different um
uh yeah probably so
probably so
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's considering doing this
well my advice would be
if you're gonna do it just make sure you
like protect yourself
because the streets don't love nobody
and
you just gotta be careful you can't
trust everybody
us black women we're queens and
we should stand tall for ourselves and
not
look at ourselves as nothing
because this is nothing walking the
streets selling our bodies like
anything could happen we could die get
raped get get kidnapped and
anything you know and living this
lifestyle i feel like
this is the the risk that i'm taking
like i could die any day
getting in cars with these tricks that i
don't know like i've been through some
[ __ ] low-key
i just never said anything to nobody
all right tiffany thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you good luck
with wherever you go from there
thank you
you